good morning boys girls and interested
others I said a couple of days ago last
week that I was going to produce three
videos on political correctness and that
the third one would be about tactics so
that's what I'm doing this morning I'll
probably produce a number of relatively
short videos on tactics because I think
that that might be more effective way to
to disseminate them and so by tactics
what I'm trying to figure out is how the
rhetoric surrounding these issues can be
translated into effective action at the
individual level so I'm hoping that
people who want to play a tactical game
with the with the PC extremists take it
upon themselves as individuals to stand
up against this and to hopefully do
something about it and and that's not
going to be an easy thing to do and
hopefully we can do it with some good
humor and on some andsome and a light
touch and a bit of detachment and in a
peaceful and thoughtful and rational way
and so I'm going to propose a game today
that I've designed with some of the
people who are helping me think this
through and I'm going to walk you
through that all right so we're going to
start by talking about the PC game and
the PC game is a form of ideologies and
what an ideology does is attempt to
simplify the world in a very radical way
so that it indicates to its holders that
they have understanding even when they
don't and in that way it reduces
uncertainty uncertainty and anxiety and
it also helps them improve their
short-term regulation because if they
can review themselves ideologue scan
view themselves as proper game players
then they can feel good about their
position in the world and so the purpose
of the PC game which I think is
technically a biased compression
algorithm what it does is it takes the
complexity of the world and compresses
it to a few simple axioms and it does
that it's a biased impression or
algorithm I think because it doesn't
accurately represent the complexity of
the world across its the full array of
detail necessary to deal with it
effectively all right so here are the
rules of the PC game and this is I think
what's taught to students on Mouse and
universities now as an alternative to
actual critical
thinking and the development of a
comprehensive and powerful and
functional individual philosophy it's
the alternative to wisdom that's one way
of looking at it okay so here are the
rules of the PC game
first of all what you do is identify an
area of human activity could be any area
of human activity could be sports it
could be writing it could be
socioeconomic status it could be the
garnering of wealth doesn't matter
anywhere where people are doing
something that can be identifiably
measured in terms of its outcome and
evaluate along that way then the next
thing you do is you note that there's a
distribution of success and of course
there is a distribution of success in
any human creative activity and it's
partly because in most human domains of
activity they're winner-take-all games
that's called a Pareto distribution you
can look that up if you want P AR eto
but most domains of human creative
achievement follow up redistribution and
that's why for example that a very small
minority of people have most of the
money it's also true that a small
minority of authors write most of the
books and a small minority of those who
sell books have the biggest bestsellers
and why a very small number of
recordings for example audio recordings
become successful and why a very small
number of players dominate each game and
it's very common so there's definitely a
distribution of success in any domain of
human activity so you note that then
what you do is identify the people who
are being successful as winners and the
people who are being relatively
unsuccessful as losers okay and then you
claim that the losers are losing only
because they are oppressed by the
winners so you can dispense with things
like competence and quality when you're
doing that and that's really useful if
you're an enemy of competence and
quality so anyways you claim that the
losers are losing because they're
oppressed by the winners then you claim
allegiance with the losers and so you
put yourself on the side of those that
you define as unfairly victimized then
that allows you to do two things one is
to feel secure in your comprehensive
explanation of the world and it also
helps if you surround yourself with
people who think exactly the same way
you do because then that oversimplified
and actually rather pathetic
comprehensive explanation
of the world never goes unchallenged
then the next thing you do is revel in
your moral superiority because what
you've done as well as oversimplifying
the world is placed yourself forever on
the side of the morally righteous and
you've been able to do that with a
minimum of cognitive effort and no out
no actual expertise and no real desire
to may or no no commitment to making a
positive change in the world because
that's a very very difficult thing it
takes years to make a positive change
even at a kind of a minut level of the
social structure so so you've
oversimplified the world you get to MIT
revel in your moral superiority and this
is the real dark side of such movements
is that whatever resentment you might
have as a consequence of construing
yourself as a victim or as identify or
because of identifying with victims
that's generated a fair bit of
resentment would you can then target
towards your newly discovered enemies
and resentment fueled targeting is a
very dangerous phenomena it's the sort
of thing that well suffice it to say
that it's a very dangerous phenomenon
then what you do is repeat the game
forever everywhere and it's it's a very
good game in that regard because you can
continually identify new domains of
human achievement and you can
continually multiply the categories of
winners and losers and you can do that
at infinitum essentially so that it's a
game that you can never then it's a game
that will never end which is part of the
reason why I'm doing what I can to try
to put a stop to it or at least put a
stop to it's perceived validity it's
really look I mean you can learn to play
this game in about two hours and that's
what people are taught to do in many
many university departments no and I
think it's I think it's absolutely
pathetic
I think it's morally reprehensible I
think it's it abandons the principle of
individual responsibility I think it's
intellectually specious I think it's
hollow I think it's badly motivated
there's almost no end to the number of
bad things that can be said about this
game okay and I think it's got out of
hand
so so why has it become necessary to do
something about this now well as I said
already I think it's gone too far of
course that's only my own personal
opinion but
I'm trying to stay attentive to the
psychological underpinnings of the
political landscape and it is my opinion
that this has gone too far and you know
PC the PC movement was quite powerful in
the 1990s although it disappeared back
into the underworld from from which it
emerged and I thought maybe at that
point we were done with it but that was
wrong because it's come back with a
vengeance especially in the last five
years and I've been trying to sort out
why that is and here's why what I think
is happening I think that the
universities especially the radical
left-leaning departments and those would
be the Women's Studies departments and
and and those those sorts of places
there's other departments that I think
are also primarily responsible there are
estimates that about 20% of social
scientists identify themselves to use a
cursed phrase as Marxists and you know I
don't think that's a very good idea
because Marxism produced the death of
millions of people in the 20th century
and if if you don't think that Marx and
was Marxism was directly responsible for
that then I would recommend that you
read Alexander Solzhenitsyn school-like
archipelago of course it's 2,700 pages
long and it's extraordinarily
emotionally draining to read but
Solzhenitsyn does an unbelievably good
job of detailing out his argument for
why the murderous excesses of places
like this tell honest Soviet Union and
Mao's China and and Vietnam and Cambodia
and all the other places where Marxist
murders took place
weren't aberrations in relationship to
Marxist ideas but the purest expression
of the of the philosophy that was
embodied inside that that doctrine so
you can read that if you want it's one
of the seminal books of the 20th century
and I don't think that you you can
actually have a reasonable dialogue
about this sort of thing if you're not
familiar with it partly because
Solzhenitsyn's book was one of the major
causes of the collapse of the Soviet
Union he eradicated any shreds of
intellectual respectability that the
doctrine upon which the Soviet Union had
been built still maintained after after
its decades of unbelievable murderous
existence so I'd recommend that you read
that before you enter into this kind of
argument but one of the things
going to do is to start to make some
videos about Solzhenitsyn and his
writing so that everybody you know has a
chance to understand what it was that he
was talking about because 2,700 pages is
a pretty long slog so anyways there have
been many many left radical left-leaning
departments training people over the
last thirty years not only in how to
think they've taught them how to play
the PC game but they explicitly trained
them how to become effective activists
and if you go on Women's Studies
websites for example I've done this with
many such websites they proudly trumpet
their training of radical leftist
activists and they're very very good at
it make no mistake and so I think the
universities have probably trained I
don't know exactly how to generate the
estimates I think the lower bound is
about 300,000 people and the upper bound
might be ten times that train them over
the last thirty years and now they exist
at many levels of the social hierarchy
and you know so at the top level of the
social hierarchy there's our political
structures and then you can fragment
that into major organizations and
fragment that into minor sub
organizations and put the individuals at
the bottom of that I think that the the
PC the PC game players have infiltrated
our institutions at many many levels of
the hierarchy and there are also now
writing legislation at the top and now
we've got a positive feedback loop going
between the legislation legislative
activities at the top and the people who
are acting as essentially insurgents for
this movement at all the levels of the
social hierarchy and it's producing an
increasingly rigidify appositive
feedback loop I think it's also you
could also think about it as an example
of what has been described as the long
march through the institution's you can
look this up on Wikipedia the long march
through the institution's but we'll look
first to say what to see what Herbert
Marcuse said about it Marquess was a
member of the Frankfurt School of
critical theory which is a Neel Marxist
school of thought he commented about
this idea of the long march through the
institution's which was a student named
Rudy Dukie in the 1960s generated this
idea and here's the idea
we have to work against the established
institutions while working within them
but not simply by boring from within
by doing the job learning how to program
and read computers how to teach at all
levels of education how to use the mass
media how to organize production how to
recognize an issue planned obsolescence
how to design etc and at the same time
preserve our consciousness in working
with others and that means our political
consciousness so you know this has
happened and it's happened at least in
part as a consequence of conscious
planning and so to me that to me that
that seems potentially very dangerous
because it doesn't take that many
committed people it doesn't take that
large of a large a committed minority to
produce substantive changes in a society
so and we see those changes happening
now and I think they're they're very
detrimental to such things as free
speech and I regard free speech as a
prerequisite to a civilized society
because freedom of speech means that you
can have combat with words that's what
it means it doesn't mean that people can
happily and gently exchange opinions it
means that we can engage in combat with
words and the battleground of ideas and
the reason that that's acceptable and
why it's acceptable that people's
feelings get hurt during that combat is
that the combat of ideas is far
preferable to actual combat and it's
also the only alternative because people
have genuine disagreements and if you
don't let them talk them out and reach
some sort of consensus some quart of
negotiated settlement then they can
either swallow their opinions and become
enraged or they can engage in actual
combat and so I think anything that
threatens freedom of speech threatens
the stability of the society and I think
the PC excesses threaten freedom of
speech and I think they threaten it
quite severely I already know people for
example at the universities who are
loathe to teach anything to do with
gender or sexual identity because
they're afraid of saying the wrong thing
and that puts a pall over over over free
discussion at the University on a whole
array of vital issues so alright so
having said that I've identified the PC
game I've identified why I think it's
dangerous and why it's spread so rapidly
I think that now we need at least in
part we need tactics to fight back and
so one of the things I'm going to
propose is a counter game and here's the
principles that I think the counter game
has to be able to
the features that the counter game has
to have it has to play be playable
everywhere because obviously the PC game
is playable everywhere it has to make
the point and the point is that there is
widespread opposition to these PC ideas
and that the opposition is is uh is is
important and needs to be attended to
carefully it has to spread fast and it
would help if it was a bit humorous
because it would be good if we could do
this with a bit of detachment and some
rationality and some careful
argumentation and some playfulness and
and some well all of that would be real
good it's not an easy thing to manage
because it's a serious business and but
you have to keep a light touch when
you're doing this sort of thing that's
one of the indications that you've
actually attained some mastery over it
so keep that in mind when you're if
you're interested in this sort of thing
so I'm going to announce Pokemon PC and
I'd like to first say that of course the
good people who produced the Pokemon
artifacts in the past and products have
nothing to do with this and so they
can't be blamed for it and I hope
they'll forgive me for using their
terminology in a satirical and political
manner it can everyone can play it's all
the rage it's spreading like wildfire
here are the rules - Pokemon PC first
purchase your starter pack of Pokemon PC
stickers so I've put them on eBay I've
ordered about 5000 of them you can buy a
starter pack of 50 or a hundred and if
you feel like doing that then I would
encourage you to do it I don't know if
people will be interested in this but
it's an experiment considered an
experiment if you're feeling really
enthusiastic buy a couple of them give
them to your friends advanced players
can purchase the accessory packs - and
the accessory packs are larger stickers
at least to begin with and I'll post
them relatively quickly so here's the
sticker so here's the design principles
we didn't want it to be black red and
white
like the anti-smoking stickers you know
because that just seemed a bit much so
we decided to make it look kind of
peaceful and playful and you know it's
it's green and purple and it's not it's
not in an in-your-face sort of thing and
this doesn't have to be an in-your-face
so
thing and so why I like the design some
of the people who are advising and
helping me I've been working on that so
that's what the PC stickers look like
there are two inches by two inches and
we've designed them
well I'll continue with the rules of the
Pokemon PC game okay so there's the
starter packs they're eBay item one two
two one six seven zero two three four
one three all of course post that online
on this YouTube website there's a snip
li-like looks like a bitly you URL for
for that particular item one hundred
sticker item is one two two one six
seven zero zero one nine zero two so you
can buy 50 sticker packs or 100 sticker
packs and then you can start using them
to play PC Pokemon and here are the
rules first take your starter pack of 50
to 100 stickers to school or work it can
be carried conveniently in a backpack a
briefcase or under your shirt if you're
a real double-oh-seven type then wander
the halls of your institution or
workplace be stealth full and if you
need to whistle nonchalantly so that
people don't know what you're up to you
lose points if you get caught too early
in the game pay careful attention while
you're doing this and I would say always
pay careful attention so this is the eye
of horus by the way it's an old Egyptian
God and the Egyptians worshipped a TED
attention as their highest deity they
regarded the careful attention that
individuals paid as the antidote to the
corruption and stagnation of the state
so Horus was an open-eyed God who
rescued his father from the underworld
and so he's the god of attention I guess
I could think about him as the patron
saint of the PC Pokemon movement okay
then now you're in your institution or
your workplace or your school and you're
wandering around and you're looking for
posters that advertise the PC game now
they described what the PC game is so
you can use your judgement about what
posters are designed to support that
game and I would say do it carefully you
know think about it and don't just put
the stickers everywhere because that
reduces their utility look at a poster
think if you think think and consider to
see if it is playing the game that I
described and if it is then stealthily
remove one of your Pokemon PC stickers
from your start
pack remove the backing if you need eye
protection while you're doing that
because you're concerned about the
danger make sure that you wear it handle
the sticker reverently then strike like
the Cobra
that's the sticker Cobra by the way and
I found this guy on the right here mono
mono is a Canadian hero mono the
Airacobra so I guess he could be another
he's our patron superhero I guess mono
the Airacobra so you strike like mono
the Airacobra Canadian super heroes by
the way are pretty rare so it's hard
alright so take your Pokemon PC sticker
and carefully place it on the lower
right side of the poster I've put an
example down here you can see there's an
example of proper placement right there
put the PC sticker on the lower right
part of the PC game poster be a little
subtle okay don't stick it obviously and
boneheaded Lee in the middle you want to
let the PC game poster continue to
broadcast its evil message but you want
to register your opposition and more
importantly you want to show that
someone's paying attention okay because
we need to show that people are paying
attention to this sort of things I don't
think the people who are playing these
games are particularly brave and so I
think if proper attention is called to
what they're doing they might wander
back into the darkness that initially
spawned them alright and then next thing
you do I would like you to do is
photograph use your cell phone to
photograph the newly modified poster and
then I want you to prepare to upload
that photo when what I hope will be the
Pokemon PC app arrives and later in the
video I'm going to call for an app
designer because I would like volunteers
to help me design an app that has a
certain number of features and more
features if you have ideas for more
features it's welcome so I would ask the
app producers to send me a proposal
you could even either do it as
volunteers or you could send me a budget
and I'll see if I can scrounge up the
money to pay for it I can certainly use
the whatever revenue might be generated
with the PC Pokemon PC stickers to
generate enough revenue maybe to develop
the app so there's an example of proper
placement be nice and careful stick it
on the lower right hand right hand side
if more than one of you come across the
same poster I suppose you could put
another sticker on there beside it that
would register a vote but another vote
say against the con
and of that poster but don't use a bunch
of stickers from your starter packs on
the same poster right so be subtle and
and intelligent about all this and
careful and awake and tough and and all
of the things that you should be if
you're a good well-functioning
individual all right then you disappear
stealthily into the night like Zorro I
guess or maybe someone else so you can
pick your stealthily disappear or and
emulate them and it's good thing to
emulate people that you admire and so
pick somebody you admire and emulate
that sucker and that'd be a good idea so
then then ten play again with another
poster yeah and again and then again and
then again and then again as long as
necessary for years if necessary all
right because this this is a long haul
this is a long haul process and this is
only the starting place as far as I can
tell so I'm going to call for an app
designer for all you people out there
who have computer ability I'd like you
to design a Pokemon PC app that can be
used as a mobile application I would
like it to be able to upload photos of
Pokemon PC stickered posters and then I
want it to link to Google Maps I don't
know how that might be done and what I
would like to have happen is that we can
get a comprehensive library of PC
posters so that's why I want you to be
very careful in what you select to
sticker and that we could also make a
map now of the of the distribution of
these posters because then we can find
out where the layers of the PC game
players are and then we can go on to the
next version of Pokemon PC which I have
to think through and which I'll announce
later and so I would say thanks for
playing kids and always remember play
Pokemon PC safely over and out